last talk is by
noam finkelstein from
i believe cornell university
so he will present remotely he will talk
about parameterization and the
cardinality bonds for latent variable
graphic models
okay
great thank you thanks very much um
thanks for having me i'm sorry i can't
be with all of you i'm very sad to be
missing the
uh in person part of the workshop but
i'm happy to be here virtually uh so
i'll be talking about work with um ellie
wolfe and ellie spitzer who are both
there in person so you can
follow up with with with me or with them
um after after the presentation
uh so the sort of big picture goal is to
of this work is to reduce the number of
unidentified model parameters to
facilitate computational approaches to
causal compatibility and also to
inference and in that way it's actually
related to the sort of closing of
richard stock so that was a nice
um and i think the part that's going to
be of most interest to physicists is the
causal compatibility question which
ellie also spoke about yesterday with
the inflation
approach
so the kind of two main things we're
going to do to try to reduce the number
of unidentified parameters is
find
lower non-restrictive latent variable
cardinalities in dag models
and second approach is going to be to
use a hybrid parametrization i'm going
to talk about what that means
so the general setting is we have
observed variables v unobserved
variables u we have some kind of latent
variable model for
for the distribution over u and v
and we call the induced model
for just the distribution of v the
marginal model
and
when you have a latent variable model
like this
when you make assumptions about the
cardinality of you it could be that
you're restricting the marginal model so
in this really simple model where a and
y share a common cause observed from a
cause
if they both have high cardinality and
you assume that you has low cardinality
you limit their correlation
and therefore the resulting model is
smaller the resulting marginal model is
smaller than if you had infinite
cardinality so the question is kind of
what can we say about
about
cardinalities of these
latent variables
so we're going to start with a really
broad view we're going to talk about
arbitrary models for discrete data
so we're going to suppose that the
observed variables can take values in a
state space omega of size d
so any model at all for the marginal
distribution over those variables has to
be a subset of the d minus one simplex
we're not specifically talking about
graphical models yet this is any model
at all
and the question is can we use the the
finite dimension of the marginal model
the fact that this is a finite
dimensional simplex to find a
non-restrictive cardinality for you
and the answer is
yes
and this is commonly done by information
theorists and the way that they do it is
through cara theodore's theorem and this
has also been used to bound late and
verbal cardinalities in
a specific class of dags
in a 2017 paper
which ellie was also a coetheron
and the theorem says
at any point in the convex hole of a set
in rm can be written as the convex
combination of n plus one points in that
set
so
how do we apply this to our latent
variable cardinality question
well we start by constructing a set in
the simplex which we denote script s
and the set is going to be made up of
the conditional distributions of the
observed data conditional on the latent
variable is equal to
little u for every little u in the state
space of u
and then we observe that the expected
value of this set taken with respect to
u
is going to be
just the marginal distribution
so any marginal distribution that's
permitted by
um
by the
complete model
is going to be the expected value of
this set
and it follows that the
true distribution marginal distribution
is in the convex whole of script s in
the relevant simplex
so where do we go from there
uh now we just all we have to do is
apply chirotheodore's theorem and we say
that
due to character development this
distribution the true distribution can
be represented as a convex combination
of d points and script s
which we
denote using this notation and in in
this case
we're going to take
the
distribution the the probabilities that
u equals little u to be the weights of
the convex combination
and the conditional distributions of v
to be the points in script
s so what that means is that
any
marginal distribution pv in the marginal
model remains in the marginal model in
other words we can express it
if we assume that u only takes values in
this state space of size d so in other
words the assumption that u has final
cardinality of d
is non-restrictive so again this is sort
of like the most general
application categories theorem that that
i could come up with but it's an idea
that's been applied
in many specific cases
um and so so far we're not talking about
um
graphical models or anything this is
just saying for any lane variable model
with um
[Music]
with discrete observed data we can bound
the cardinality of view and you were a
little bit glossing over the idea of
what if there are multiple lane
variables
it doesn't really matter you can kind of
marginalize out the remaining lane
variables and apply this to one lane
variable at a time
so let's just look at a quick example of
a causal latent variable dag
so if we're considering this kind of
causal even we're modeling
the factual version of a and then
counterfactual versions of m after
intervention on a counter fractional
versions of y after intervention on m so
if we assume the variables are binary
we get five
random variables
and so the sample space for the observed
variables is
two to the five so
it's a combinatorial space it's 32. so
we can say that you know the one bound
for for the cardinality of u or one
non-restrictive cardinality of u is
going to be 32. people often talk about
these as bounds on you um and of course
you are sort of like potentially
infinite dimensional and you can't
really bound it so
i i like to talk about non-restrictive
cardinalities or balance on
non-restrictive cardinalities
um
i i don't know if i would notice if
anybody had any questions so i hope
somebody will tell me if so
i'll just continue until that point
um
so if we kind of just extend the idea we
just looked at
to apply these to apply the same idea to
causal latent variable dags in general
so for each
observed variable in the dag we have to
model one variable for every setting of
its observed parents these are the one
step ahead counterfactuals
and
what that means is you know if we let
script x sub v and script
so parents of v denote the state space
of the variable b and its parents
respectively then the
total sample space for
uh
the variables that we're modeling is
going to be given by this product
um and if you have
you know this can get really big really
fast if you have
multiple parents of v
then you have this kind of combinatorial
combinatorially sized thing which is
anyway in an exponent
so uh so this is kind of our starting
point and then our question is how much
can we
improve on this and this is the same uh
cardinality the same nonrestrictive
cardinality
applied at the district level not at the
graph level
that was given
in a recent paper a 2021 paper by
jiang
and company with a very different proof
strategy
okay so there are a number of
really simple things that we can do um
to reduce
the cardinality balance or we're going
to start with kind of the simplest of
them which is to say
the number of variables that we need to
model kind of depends on what we're
interested in
you know a couple of slides ago we
considered sort of the causal model so
all of the one step ahead counter
factuals
but it could be that if we're interested
in something like causal compatibility
we only need to model
the factual random variables so if we
only model the fractional random
variables there are only three of them
we get a
a sample a sample space of size eight
and we can therefore say you know if we
assume you to have quantity of eight
that's that's a non-restrictive
assumption
um more generally
uh we can kind of pick and choose which
kind of fractions we want to model so if
we're interested in some kind of
inference question causal inference
question we might want to model counter
factual versions of y
um but we might not care about counter
factual versions of a and m
so you can end up in a scenario where if
you have kind of factual a factual m and
then the two counterfactual versions of
y
you have
four random variables
and uh
and therefore you get a cardinality of
16. so the kind of
uh thought here is that the
nonrestrictive cardinality actually
depends on
what we need to model in terms of the
counterfactual variables the less we
model
the lower the cardinality um and and i
think in most applications you don't end
up needing to model
all of the counterfactual random
variables um so this was you know this
is maybe slightly unintuitive which is
that if you want to kind of answer a
causal inference question
you end up with a different
non-restrictive cardinality than if you
want to answer a causal compatibility
question
um
and uh and that's just because
you're modeling
more variables
okay so the next kind of simple thing we
can do is we can notice that um equality
constraints reduce model dimension so so
now let's assume we're only interested
in the factual random variables we have
maybe a causal compatibility question
um
and
so we don't care about counterfactuals
so we only have four variables here and
if variables are binary then
any any model over these four variables
is going to be a point in the 15 simplex
in addition to this information we also
know there are four equality constraints
due to the structure of this model
two of them are from z being independent
of m given a so you get one for each
value of a
and then you get two from z being
independent of y after intervention on m
which is an identified distribution you
get one for each value of m
and so using these four quality
constraints we could say you know the
real dimension of the model is 11
instead of 15. why is that because
four
sort of dimensions of the model can be
exactly uh our deterministic functions
of the remaining
dimensions
um and so visually we can kind of think
about this as
lower model dimensions goes to lower
cardinality bounds and the reason is
that if you start off on the right hand
side and you have
this sort of blue blob represents the
model
in the simplex and you kind of
if you know you have an equality
constraint what that means is that one
of the dimensions is not really there
and you can just project onto a lower
dimensional
space without losing any information
and then you can apply a character doors
bound in a lower dimensional space and
if you remember the bound is just in
terms of the dimensionality of the space
so you get a lower non-restrictive
cardinality
um okay
so
aside from that we can
keep going
um
so even once we reduce the dimension
dimensionality of the model through
you know these kind of simpler ideas
we can notice that the distribution
that some of the dimensions that remain
might not be relevant so
the distribution of u
isn't going to touch several of the
dimensions and i'll
explain what i mean by that in a minute
but the sort of intuition is that no
matter what you do to you
you're not going to change the marginal
distribution of z and you're not going
to change the conditional distribution
of m given a
so
you know no matter what you do to you
means that you can change its
distribution you can change its
cardinality you can do whatever you want
and so in some sense we should get a
discount for these uh
these uh points that the u isn't gonna
be able to change
uh so how do we encode that um we use
nested markov parameterization uh so
this is a a really nice parametrization
for the nested markov model which was
introduced by
robin evans and thomas richardson who
are
organizing this workshop
um
and so it has the the parameterization
has two really nice properties
um
the
number of nested markov parameters is
equal to the dimension of the nested
markov model which
has been shown to be equal to the
dimension of the marginal model i
believe also by robin evans
which means that you get essentially one
parameter per dimension
and the second really nice property is
that each parameter has a causal
interpretation
and the causal interpretation can be
used to obtain a graphical criterion for
relevant laying variables for each
parameter
so
let's
look at that more closely for a moment
so if we again return to this graph
we'll consider nested markov parameters
for this graph or at least one of them
nested markov parameters in general take
the form of
being the probability of some event
conditional on
you know the probability that a set of
variables observe variables a
take certain values conditional on
observed variables b takes
values under intervention on c
so in this case one of the nested markov
parameters is
the probability that
uh
upon intervention a equals zero the
variable m
takes the value zero
um and so we can represent uh the sort
of model for
uh what happens when you intervene on a
with uh the swig graph which which has
been discussed in previous talks
um
but
if you look at this graph you'll notice
that u is independent
of
m after intervention on a
and so what that means is that
no matter how i change the distribution
of u
um
nothing about the this probability is
going to change and in particular if i
alter the cardinality of u
nothing about this probability is is
going to change
um
and so
the kind of
um sorry i'm seeing a question in the
chat
irrelevant for the effect of a on y um
it's so the idea of relevance so the
question in the chat is irrelevant for
the effect of a on y uh so
uh
i'm gonna
say
is that from
okay so i'm gonna
try to to adjust that as best as i can
and then if i have not addressed that
well maybe there could be a follow-up
but um so the idea of relevance that
we're talking about is not so much
um
for any particular
uh
causal parameter
what we're looking for is nested markov
parameters that cannot be affected by
the distribution of u so in other words
that are not a function of the
distribution view so if i change the
distribution of u
uh
which nested markov parameters are going
to be impossible or are not going to
change do we already know we're not
going to change as a result of the model
so in this case if i change the
distribution of u
we know that this probability can't
change
so that's that's the notion of relevance
that we're that we're using
i hope that answers the question
okay
um and so the way that we formalized
that uh the sort of result that that
intuition leads to um is that the
cardinality of any latent variable u can
without restricting the marginal model
be assumed to be
the size of the set of nested markov
parameters such that
a u is not a separated from ai
a conditional on bi upon deletion of ci
where
ai bi and ci are um
are sort of the
variables uh to the left of to the right
of and in the due conditional for the
corresponding nested markov parameter
and the idea again is just that if the
leading variable is conditionally
independent of an event after
intervention
uh changes in the distribution of that
variable and therefore the cardinality
are not going to affect the probability
so that it's not going to affect the
missing markov parameter
and as a result the nested markov
parameter that sort of dimension of the
model doesn't need to be considered as a
dimension of the space to which
characteristic theorem is applied
um so again using just the same graph
now we're kind of thinking about a
slightly different thing which is
a sort of herd latent variable uh notion
of dropping irrelevant dimensions so for
a particular land variable you know even
if you can't
project from a sort of three-dimensional
space to two-dimensional space
um
even if you don't have a sort of
bijective function between these two
it could be that for a particular latent
variable
the
extra information that you're losing by
doing this projection
is irrelevant to that latent variable
and so again we can apply sort of
characteristic theorem in this lower
dimensional space and therefore get a
lower
non-restrictive cardinality
i can ask questions
yes please for the nasty the mark curve
of parameters do we know it's
cardinality like how many
parameters do we have given a model
so there's an algorithm and actually i'm
probably like the
20th best person in the room to answer
this question given that the uh
nested markov folks are all here but um
there's an algorithm that will produce
the parameters i do not believe that
there is a closed form
[Music]
a closed form expression for the number
of parameters given a graph
okay
although feel free to correct me if i'm
if i'm wrong
okay so
okay so why why bother doing all this so
i'll give a
bit of a simple example that shows
kind of the benefit
of
reducing these cardinalities or finding
lower non-restrictive cardinalities so
if we do the simple kind of
[Music]
characteristic cardinality that i i
mentioned at the at the at the start of
the talk which was the one in the
uh
general 2021 paper
the cardinality is going to be
2 to the k plus 1 for all for every
leading variable in this chain so this
is a simple example which is just a
sort of sequence of observed variables
x1 through xk plus 1 and each adjacent
pair
a variable shares an independent
latent parent
independent common latent parent we're
going to assume that all of the x's are
binary
and so
here we have that the
non-restrictive cardinalities are
exponential in the length of the chain
um if we apply the improved
cardinalities based on the sort of
nested markov parameterization idea
we get
a sort of different
um
[Music]
we get kind of much lower numbers
so just for context when we get to for
example k equals 11
um
according to the
kind of naive bound or a simpler bound
uh we would have to say each u has an
intersection of primarily of two to the
twelve which is four thousand ninety six
um and if we look at kind of the
non-restrictive cardinalities for each
of the u's
um using the relevant nested markov
parameters we you know the
largest one is 48
and i think it's just kind of worth
looking at the uh
the shape of these non-restrictive
cardinalities you'll notice that they
all kind of look like a pyramid you know
you start small i mean you start
relatively small and then you go up
you reach kind of the high point and
then you go back down and they're
symmetrical
and the kind of
intuition for that is that uh you know
the part of the model that u1 is
involved with
kind of falls off a cliff
immediately to the
to the left let's say
immediately towards the start of the
chain kind of can't extend influence
past
x1
it can only really extend influence in
the other direction
um and so the kind of scope of its
influence the number of dimensions that
it touches kind of intuitively should be
smaller and that should kind of increase
as you move towards the middle of the
chain and then decrease again um and
uh so as i mentioned there isn't a
closed form
expression for for the number of
uh nested markov parameters uh and we
also don't have a closed form expression
for the number of relevance nested
markov parameters given
um a graph so it's a little bit hard to
figure out
exactly how
how these non-restrictive cardinalities
scale
with the length of the chain in this
case
but you know if you kind of look you'll
see an interesting pattern which is you
know u1
the cardinality of u1 scales linearly
it's just for every increase in k you
increase by the nonrestrictive
cardinality by two
and u2 also scales linearly for every
increase in in k you increase the
non-restrictive criterion by three
and
in this case it's by four in this case
it's by five
and so on and so it kind of you know
depending on how you want to count um
you could say that you know the the
cardinality the non-restrictive
cardinality scale
uh linearly
i think if if instead you look at kind
of the max cardinality for each
length of the chain you'll get two
quadratic scaling
um but in either case it's it's kind of
a
somewhat better situation than
the exponential
scaling um and this is a little bit of
like i said a little bit of a contrived
example um
the benefits of doing this are going to
be
better in in sparse graphs and the more
interconnected the graph is
um the less benefit you're going to get
and in the sort of um
in sort of case where the graph is
completely interconnected in the sense
that there's a single outlane variable
that's apparent of everything
you'll get just the same
the same bound
okay
i'm going to check the chat
um
so there's a question in the chat that
says are the nested mark off parameters
for the dag or for the admg um and so
the nested markup parameters are for
uh
i guess it depends on how you want to
how how you want to find that question
but i'm going to choose to price it is
that the nest markov parameters are for
the admg um
but
because uh so so the marginal model is
going to be a sub model of the
nested markov model
and so because it's a submodel and it
has the same
dimension
we kind of pretend that they're
parameters for the marginal model
which means that there are certain
settings of
nested markov parameters that would uh
be outside of the marginal model which
is not the case for the nested markov
model
um
i don't know if i've answered that
question but uh yeah okay
um repeat what's the question
sorry the question was are the nested
markup parameters for the dag or for the
admg
um and my answer is pretty much uh so so
what i
uh understand this question to me is
that uh the so an admg is
a uh
is a
graph with two kinds of edges um
directed edges and bi-directed edges
um and the bi-directed edges come about
by projecting out latent variables and
replacing any uh
introducing biodirected edge between any
two observed variables that share a
leading parent
and
avmgs
i think are tend to be associated with
the nested markov model which is a
supermodel of the marginal model of a
lane variable dag
and so the question was are the nested
markov permits for the dagger for the
admg
and and my answer is we're using the
uh derivation for the admg for the
nested markov model uh in addition to a
result that that says that
the nested market model is the same
dimension as the marginal model
but i can go into more detail on that uh
later or as desired ask for the question
to clarify the
you mentioned the dimensionality also
related to what kind of counterfactuals
you want to model so this reduction for
arbitrary counterfactuals or
is just for observe observational
distribution
yeah that's a good question so uh the
nested mark of reduction uh is
um for the observed it's a
for the
not not for arbitrary conflictuals it's
just for the observed
uh observed data distribution so if you
want to model some if you want to model
all counter fractionals then it doesn't
really matter you just you need kind of
the um
well
i guess it gets
very complicated when you start thinking
about
modeling some kind of factuals um
or applying something like the nested
markov parameterization to modeling all
kind of factuals
and that's something that we have
thought a little about but uh
isn't is not um
i don't i don't have any good answers
for
um so yeah so the nested mark of
reduction is is in this case for the
observed
variables
okay um
so okay so so far we've talked about
basically reducing
uh the cardinality or the
non-restrictive credibility of latent
variables
um
there is
one other kind of way of thinking about
this that i'll introduce here um
so you know if we look at this very same
graph uh
one way of thinking about u1 is that the
it it's going to contain all the
information shared between x1 and x2 and
so
what that means it's going to contain at
most all the all the random noise
necessary to determine the value of x1
i can't con it
we can assume non-restrictively that
it's not going to contain more than that
um
because if it did then you know that
that noise just doesn't have to be
shared between x1 and x2 and doesn't
have to be part of u1
um so that requires that u1 only has to
have cardinality equal to x1 in other
words x1 can just copy u1
x1 doesn't have any other parents so it
doesn't need to specify any other
response functions
or anything like that
and you can kind of continue along these
lines you can say well if u1
sort of determines x1 then u2 is going
to determine x2 in response to u1
and you can kind of continue all the way
down the chain the problem is that the
required cardinalities explode very very
quickly by the time you get to u4 you're
already
two to the 513 and this idea of tasking
especially in a context like this is
very closely related to
gearings and functional models
in another paper by
robin evans
um
but
the sort of one one thing to point out
is that by the tasking logic u1 can be
seen to have a cardinality of two and
that beats the previous non-restricted
non-restrictive cardinalities for u1
regardless of k for any k and so we can
use these kind of tasking based
cardinalities
in conjunction with the improved
characteristic cardinalities because
neither one requires us to either
depends on the cardinalities of other
relating variables
um
okay
uh how am i doing on time
okay
10 minutes um so uh so i'm going to talk
a little bit more about
the idea of tasking and the idea of a
hybrid parameterization
so
i think many of you will have seen
representations of a
causal models that look like this
um and the kind of interpretation of
these models is that the
the epsilon
variables
uh encode uh all of the all the
randomness about each of the
um other variables so one way to think
about this and this is the way that uh
balkan pearl i think first introduced
thinking about the ib model has been
discussed earlier today as well
is that these epsilon variables actually
encode
response functions of each of the
variables to its parents
so the epsilon variables actually take a
value in the state space of functions
from the values of the parents of a
variable to the values of that variable
so
one way to think about tasking is
uh this is making the assumption and you
can do this non-restrictively and the
same way the bulk and pearl did it
making the assumption that uh
comma a common parents of two observed
variables contains all of the noise
relevant to determining
each of those variables in response to
their parents
and so in this case if we say u is
tasked with determining a and y
all we're saying is that u sort of
contains epsilon a and epsilon y and
doesn't contain anything else that means
it has to take a value in the sort of
cross base of functions
of parents of a to a and parents of y to
y um
so
if we think about
parameterizations so again one of our
goals was reducing unidentified
parameters thinking about about
parameterizations
once we've done this kind of tasking
only u and epsilon m are random
uh uh a m and y are determined by u and
f on m what that means is we only have
to parameterize the marginal
distributions of u and epsilon and we
don't have to parameterize
anything else
and that might reduce the number of
parameters which we'll look at more
carefully
in a moment
um so
it turns out we can do a little bit
better than this in terms of the number
of unidentified parameters and so if we
again think about this kind of
conception of tasking you to determine a
and y we'll notice that epsilon m is not
identified because the response the
probabilities of each response function
of m to a is not identified but the sort
of conventional conditional distribution
m given a is identified
um and so what that means is that we can
parameterize the
distribution of u functionally in terms
of this kind of idea of tasking
um
in terms of a distribution over elements
of this space here
um but we can parameters the conditional
distribution m given a using
conventional dot parameters which are
identified
and that means that you know we don't
have to add additional unidentified
parameters so the sort of basic idea of
the hybrid parameterization
uh is that you know we have this tasking
option if we task a leading variable
it's often going to increase its
non-restrictive cardinality relative to
the characteristic bound but it can
reduce the total number of parameters
because you don't have to parameterize
the distribution of the observed
variables
so the idea of the hybrid
parametrizations is that um
we task latent variables if doing so
decreases the number of unidentified
parameters otherwise we just use the
characteristic bound with with the
standard dac parameters
and the approach to figuring out what we
task and what we use the car theodore
bond
at this point is pretty heuristic and we
don't have like an awful way of doing it
but we have some some ideas about it um
so let's just just run through an
example of what that looks like
i'm going to pull up the same graph
again we've tasked you to determine and
y and then we're going to use the dog
parameters for m
if we if we were to just use the dac
parameterization so if we were to find
you know the best non-restrictive
uh cardinality of u that we could and
then parameterize its marginal
distribution and then the conditional
g a given u and so on we'd get 25 total
parameters and 23 of them would be
unidentified the only two that would be
identified are for the conditional
distributions of m given a
if we do the functional parameterization
which is we task u is determining a and
y and then we parameterize the noise
term for m we have 10 parameters which
is fewer
but they're all unidentified because
they all involve counterfactual
information across the world fun factual
information
and if we do the hybrid parameterization
which is what i talked about earlier
which is we task u but then use the dag
parameters for m we get nine total
parameters and only seven of them are
unidentified so this is the kind of
thing we can do
with um
with the hybrid parameterization
um so the idea of tasking can get
complicated i kind of gave a really
simple example but there are a few
complications so suppose we say we want
to task u1 with determining
a in response to z so in other words u1
is going to contain
all the noise necessary to determine a
with response to z in response to z
and u2 um that's actually one
complication not mentioned on the slide
so if we you know know the bound for u2
then we can say you know how how big
does epsilon a have to be assume that a
sun is is a subset of u1
the problem is that if that's all u1 is
doing
it can't contain any noise that's
relevant to z and y but not relevant to
a and that alters the model so if we say
u1 all u1 has to worry about is
determining a in response to its parents
then we're going to
lose shared information between
z and y
because there's no other avenue for
shared information between z and y
that's not relevant to a
and so
to task in a way that's non-restrictive
we have to add a few kind of caveats
uh so so you can only do this kind of
tasking if
uh one you shares no children with the
previously tasked variable
and two
the case that we just discussed a new
unobserved parent of an uh undetermined
children of u is added to the graph if
one does not exist so in other words if
we decide
uh
us u1 is going to be tasked with
determining a then we have to add a new
parent to capture the remaining
spillover randomness that's shared
between z and y and this is a typo
repeat of one uh sorry about that
okay and so now really briefly to wrap
up
um
so
you know i said at the start of the goal
is to kind of uh improve computational
tractability for for causal
compatibility and inference questions um
you know so we went through
uh sort of improved non-restrictive
cardinality bounds which
are of interest in some cases uh
themselves but our main goal is to kind
of consider
this polynomial system formulation of um
marginal models of dags and so it's sort
of
it was recognized i think a long time
ago for example by geiger and meek
that a distribution is in the marginal
model of a graph it can be expressed
according to
this polynomial equation with one
equation for every
setting of
the observed variables
and we we get a summation here instead
of an integral because
we can assume non-restrictively that
you take values in finite state spaces
and so we can
solve the causal compatibility question
by checking whether
there are
values of unidentified parameters on the
right-hand side of these equations that
satisfy all of the equations
if so then the distribution is in the
model if not then it's not in the model
the problem is that the runtime of these
satisfiability algorithms is exponential
in the number of unidentified model
parameters and so that's why uh you know
we we're trying to reduce the number of
unidentified model parameters in in all
these uh
ways that i've described so let's just
look at a quick example of that
um
i guess i'm kind of running a lot of
time so i won't go through this in
detail but this is just the polynomial
system that i described where
unidentified model parameters are given
in red identified ones are in blue
as richard mentioned for i think i think
it was discussed in the linear case but
this is also
noted in the
jing at all paper that i've mentioned a
few times you can also do
polynomial programming
to do causal inference to address causal
inference problems and we also have some
work on this with colleagues from from
upenn
um
yeah and i guess i'm gonna just skip
through the last little bit
and get to conclusions
so
the kind of takeaways from this talk are
so even a simple model can have a lot of
unidentified parameters but there are a
number of things that you can do if
you're using one of these computational
methods that uh
scale
in complexity with the number of
unidentified parameters
so you can improve the non-restrictive
cardinality bond you can use the hybrid
parameterization
um
these two are in the science of this
gift but i'd be happy to answer more
questions about them
and the last thing that i want to
mention is that
if you look at
these
polynomial systems they have kind of a
very very specific structure so you have
these
uh
you have you know all of the equations
in the system have the same number of
terms all the terms have the same degree
um and so on and so forth and i think uh
there's probably a
polynomial satisfiability algorithm that
can take advantage of that
structure there's also kind of a
very specific structure and how
parameters are shared across
equations and so
in terms of
speeding up um
causal compatibility queries i think
that is an interesting venue for for
future work
um so yep that i think that's uh that's
it that's it for me so thank you very
much for listening
thanks for the talk uh i have two
questions one about i guess a required
equation patient question can go back to
the slide where you mentioned the
complication of tasking where you have
to split the u
yeah that one um
yeah oh i guess yeah i misunderstood
yeah i think that's fine okay uh
so i guess my main question is uh do you
have any idea about proving a lower
bound for this type of problem
um that's a really good question so i
think in some cases it's easy to prove a
lower bound and these are kind of
trivial cases so there's um
i i i uh there there's a
paper also about calvin evans uh
whose work has clearly uh influenced
this work
um but where uh he presents a sort of um
criterion for
late variable
uh dag equivalents
and one of the results which which i
think actually specific result um was
known
before that as well is that um
you know these two models the marginal
models of these two main variable dags
are equal
and so of course that means the the
lower you know the non-restrictive
cardinality of u can be zero you don't
need it at all um
uh so that's that's a little bit of a
a trivial answer uh in general in cases
where that doesn't uh apply
um i haven't spent a lot of time
thinking about lower bounds and i don't
uh i don't have a good
sort of
non-trivial answer to that question
so this is thomas i just wanted to
follow up on the question i think that
jin asked about what was the nest of
markov model parameterizing and so it is
also parametrizing it is parametrizing
the observed distribution but it's also
parametrizing
all of the identified causal
intervention distributions
thanks thanks for that qualification i
understand the next markov model likes
the exclusive inequalities
does that have any impact on this
parameterization cardinality no no sir
yeah it shouldn't um
and that's and that's because the nested
american model has been shown to be of
the same dimension as the marginal model
so if it you know i guess
it would have been plausible that the
marginal model had lower dimensional
which meant it would have included
quality constraints not captured by the
nested markov model and in that case um
there would be you know a way to improve
this cardinality
by taking advantage of those equality
constraints as well but that's that's
been shown not to be the case it
captures all the quality constraints
any other questions
okay nice thanks speaker again
thanks very much
to uh frederick has an announcement